this election made me feel as excited as
Steve Harvey hosting family feud when
there's two white families that day but
now that it's over let's stop saying the
two candidates were similar Hillary you
may be everything that is wrong with
politics but Trump is everything that is
wrong with humanity the difference
between them is the difference between
getting in the ass by a person
who knows how to properly you in
the ass because they watch someone else
do it well for eight years and getting
in the eye socket by a
belligerent failure who at the age of 70
decides though it might be fun to start
poking people in the eye socket and
honestly getting in the eye
socket it doesn't seem like the worst
idea right now because at least then I
won't have to see just how terrible
things are going to get
[Music]
certain people don't get Superman
including the entire team of people that
are currently making his movie they
think Superman is just a goofy dope with
his underwear on the outside it gets
outshined by any other hero on-screen
not true Superman is a hard-working
illegal alien from far far away that got
adopted by two nights old white people
from Kansas that didn't even teach me to
be racist that's way more impressive
than a set billionaire named Bruce who's
only power is not being able to let go
some Cech if that happened 30 years ago
get over it
award shows are overly long masturbatory
and overlooked great outside the box
projects because they don't feature it
slavery aids or the Holocaust but they
aren't meaningless for every person that
wins there's a pile of losers sewing and
tuxedos know me they won't get the kind
of perfect blowjob you only receive when
you thank your wife in an acceptance
speech and there is a lot of meeting and
watching people that look better than
you and make more money than you be sad
and feel like they're as much of a
failure as you are which is a really
positive way of thinking about it
[Music]